hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round seven of the London
chest classic and it's quite a matchup
Sergei car cane with the white pieces
against Maxine Varsha holograph
with the black pieces and you all know
that
Sergei car cane has a guaranteed spot in
the candidates because he won the
candidates last year he was the
challenger to Magnus Carlsen and
everyone was very sad that in in for
example in December's rating world chess
rating list
Maxim Bashir Allah Grove is number five
in the world with a rating of twenty
seven hundred and eighty nine only ten
ten points below chakra and my media
room and Fabiano Caruana and only levin
aragon and magnus carlsen are in the
twenty eight hundred club so it's a it's
quite a matchup and the Huracan didn't
really have any spectacular results in
2017 but that might be one of the
reasons he has a guaranteed spot in the
candidates and maybe he is saving all of
his you know crazy surprises for that
tournament so who knows we might see a
totally different circuit car cane in
the candidates like like a hurricane 2.0
or a Super Saiyan Sergey Kerrigan that
being said let's see how this game went
Sergei has the white pieces and already
on the first move we have a lot of
excitement he plays efore and playing g4
against the Maxine means that you have
to be like a master of the Sicilian I
Dorf c5 by Maxine the Sicilian defense
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captors on d4
Knight captures on d4 and Knight to f6
and we have a Knight to c3 and here it
comes the famous a six-night or
variation Bishop to g5 e 6f for h6
Bishop to h4 and now Queen to b6 going
for that B to pawn and the here circuit
plays a three and this a three has been
played a lot lately
Maxine goes Bishop d7 for those of you
who are new to this channel or may be
new to chess in general you can't
capture the pawn on be too nice to a4
and your queen is trapped so after a
three Bishop to e7
Bishop - f - now I'm the queen on v6
threatening all sorts of ideas like
knife characters on e6 Queen to c7
getting the Queen out of the way
Queen to have three developing the Queen
preparing the castle a knight bt7 here
we have a queenside castle and b5 and
it's a very nice position for black
black already started his Queen side
expansion and is ready to attack
g4 Cara can now has to push on the King
side Bishop to b7 Bishop to g2 and we
have g5 now and probably the best idea
for kurakin in this situation is
something like f5 pushing the pawn and
after Knight to e5 Queen e2 and it's
it's a perfectly fine position for
Kerrigan and and for magazine as well
but after g5 occur can played h4 and
it's it's a very sharp idea G captures
on f4 was played g5 now by Parkin nice -
if I first would attempt on the Queen
Queen to f4 capturing H captures on g5 h
captures on g5 and our characters on h1
rook captures on h1 and night F to d7
and you can see that this bishop is
eyeing the g5 pawn it cat can't capture
it like right away but you can see that
the queen is lined up with the Queen on
this dark square diagonal so this is
never never a pleasant situation when
when this is happening to you and you
don't like this you always have to
calculate what if we can capture now
what if you can capture now so in the
spirit of that King to be won by
Kerrigan queenside castle I would have
worked to h3 now with ideas of
supporting the pawn and maybe if this
night ever moves rook can come to c3 and
harass the Queen and the king so Maxine
was king to b8 getting rid of this once
and for all
Bishop to e3 rocked the g8 now now
pressuring this g5 pawn rook the g3
adding more defense to it roof to g7
Bishop to h3 now rook to
h7 and queen - f - i'm that b6 square
now for example night to b6 with ideas
of 94 or c4 is impossible because simply
knife captures on e6 you capture and
then Bishop captures this night on b6 so
after queen - f - night the c5 was
played adding more pressure to the e4
pawn bishop - g2 defending and Queen to
c8 Quinta CA twit ideas of Bishop to d8
and then Bishop to b6 transferring this
Bishop on this powerful diagonal as it
will be much more active their Bishop to
c1 we have Bishop to d8 and Knight to f3
kurakin offers an exchange of nice and
we have 9th - g6 and maxeen isn't
interested and hurricane brings the
knight back Knight to d4 and maxeen
brings his knight back as well Knight to
e5 we have Knight to f3 again Knight to
g6 and hurricane repeats again tonight's
the d4 and if a mock scene played Knight
to e5 one more time Kerrigan could
simply repeat the knight to f3 and call
a three-fold repetition it would be a
draw but - Maxime isn't interested in a
draw even though he has the black pieces
that's very nice
he plays Bishop to b6 Bishop to e3
we have Knight to e5 now and now B 3 and
this b3 isn't isn't really the best move
it weakens the knight on c3 it's you
know don't push a pawn if if you're not
gaining anything by it once you push a
pawn you can never unpause it so maybe
maybe the Queen to e1 or maybe maybe
Knight to b3 both of these moves would
still you know leave the ball in blacks
court but after be three we have rook to
h4 now and now this comes what ideas
now this pawn is attacked three times
from the rook from the night from the
bishop and there are ideas like after
this Knight moves for example then you
open up the attack from the Queen to the
night so Knight d2 e - and this prevents
our capturing the pawn because now
you've opened up the attack from the
bishop to the b6 bishop
for example if you capture knife
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
the rook captures and not simply Bishop
captures and b6 and you're down apiece
so after Knight d2 d2 Queen the c7 now
protecting this Bishop on b6 and Bishop
to d4 again
indirectly protecting the pawn because
even now you can't capture if you
capture then Knight captures Bishop
captures Bishop captures Bishop captures
now on d4 and now Queen captures on d4
and while black does have this move b5
now you've pinned the bishop
Knight to c3 and after captures captures
it's a it's a better position for white
so after Bishop to d4 Knight C to d7 was
played offering an exchange of bishops
we have Bishop captures on b6 Queen
captures on b6 Queen captures on b6 and
the knight captors on b6 Karekin
accepted the Queen trade but and now now
it's now it's an endgame and the the
real problem for kurakin here is this
week g5 pawn and there were there were
opportunities where Kerrigan could have
pushed to g6 before this night ever came
to e5 either to break this point small
pawn chain or you know just just to
activate the rook so night the d4 we
have Knight to g6 now King to see one
now kurakin is bringing the King into
the game Knight to d7 king b2 Knight to
f4 and King III and okay the King is
activated nice capture Sanji to rock
actress Angie - and wrote to h3 with
check King has to go to d1 to protect
the knight on c3 and it would as you can
see it would be a much more enjoyable
endgame if this pawn was never on b3 if
it wasn't be to protecting the night
maybe none of this would have happened
and maybe you know maybe it would be
easier to draw this King to d2 we have
Knight to e5 now a knight D - E - nice -
f3 in with check King has to go to see
one now 9th to h4 attacking the rook
rook to g1 and Knight to g6
King 2d2 we have King c7 now maxime is
activating his skin as well
Knight to d4 King d7 rook to f1
attacking the f7 pawn but simple King g7
rogue back to g1 that rook has to
protect the g5 pawn Knight to e5 will
rock - G - Bishop - a8 the night - D - E
- and Knight to f3 check King goes to C
1 and now Rob to H 1 check King has to
go all the way back to be 2 and now
Knight to h4 Rock g4 and Knight to g6
again Knight to a4 here offering an
exchange of nights but it's not really
something it's it's not good for White
Knight captures rook captures an hour up
to g1 and now you're losing the g5 pawn
rook rook to h4 Rock capture son g5
knocking to c1 trying to activate the
King again and it's interesting how this
king went king c1 King D - King III and
then we had to went back in d2 king c1
and king b2 all the way simply because
this b3 move was played d5 and here
after pushing d5 sorry Kerrigan resigned
at the game so yeah I mean is it is it
an early resignation not really I mean
you could say he's only down upon but
after he captures Bishop captures Knight
captures and rook captures yes this is a
rook ending and you are only up one
point but these are two protected passed
pawns and this is this is unstoppable
so there's no point in playing this and
car cane resigns you know justifiably so
yeah it's like it's like Yaser said
after hurricane committed that great
crime against chess accepting a draw
from Aragon in a winning position then
of course he lost the game against
Caruana in the next round
that was his punishment and now you know
it's like a downward spiral
he didn't make any mistakes this game
any blunders but hearing played the best
moves and
Maxine played the best moves and this is
the result so yeah a very nice game and
the prior to this game I forgot to say
two of them played 8 games and the
result was a draw
caro-kann won two games Maxine won two
games and the four games were drawn so
this was like their ninth classical game
a game in their in their lives and now
Maxine wanted and now Maxine is in the
lead so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Aaron lots I had Sleiman a boil
Thomas nobly and Michael warden for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot
of really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here I will
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some nice games
from the London chess classic around
8:00 see you soon